so here's your advantage for being here
early
is uh i'm from british columbia so i
flew down through vancouver to auckland
direct flight highly recommended air new
zealand they do it well uh it's good to
be back i was actually born in new
zealand uh i left when i was three
family farms in town i'll go visit them
next week first time in two years oddly
enough i could have quarantined and gone
in but you know then i wouldn't be
married anymore and that's a separate
set of issues
uh can we switch over
there we go so uh what does it mean to
be from british columbia it means i get
to show you a bear picture this is what
you get for getting up early
so my house on the left my neighbor's
place on the right in behind us is just
forest
and uh this is a wednesday morning about
six a.m or so
and that's garbage day in my
neighborhood and so this guy wanders
through until i put the camera up i
didn't realize it because they're pretty
stealthy you know for 200 kilos uh but
he's just checking to see if i put up my
garbage early
now he's pretty good bear as uh bears go
because if you do put your garbage out
early which will get you a fine it's a
big deal in my part of the world uh
he'll just tip the can over take one of
the bags go back into the forest with it
and spread it out down in there
it's kind of like the bear takes your
garbage out for you it's not a bad deal
uh but it um
we
do you guys have all the spiders and
snakes and scary things like that we got
bears but bears are really you get used
to living with them this is a
comfortable cohabitation
uh you could smell them coming you know
what a wet dog smells like
times ten
yeah yo bears don't sneak up on you
you're like
there's bear
if you haven't run across me before i
make a few podcasts city.net rocks
listeners
awesome so my friend carl franklin
started.net rocks back in 2002 which is
three years before the word podcast
existed
and he brought me on board as the
co-host in 2005 at show 100
and in two weeks we will publish show
so we are persistent
and we actually recorded that 1800
episode at nbc london a couple of weeks
ago on stage
i also make an it show called runners
radio which i've been doing every
wednesday since april of 2007.
again persistence or 800 something of
that and for a brief interval
we for three years we made a show called
the tablet show which was when we
weren't sure if.net rocked or not it was
a dark time and so this was our backup
show and then eventually we knew.net
rocks again and we rolled it back in
that's how all those happen
free to download they're an hour to a
half hour many of the speakers you'll
see here have been on the show before
it's so sort of a common format we're
just trying to talk to the smartest
people we know about what's going on in
our industry and how we can be better
and really this talk comes from this job
i am very fortunate to be able to talk
to a huge array of people pretty much
all the time right more or less it's
become my job to think about what we
need to know in technology in the next
year or so
and it's uh william gibson another
vancouverite the guy who wrote
neuromancer joined the term cyberspace
while writing it on a wedgewood
typewriter who said the future is here
it's just not evenly distributed
and so
by interviewing all these cool folks i
can often see the future bits that
they're working on that are going to
reach more of us and then the challenges
sort of sort of get out but predictions
are hard and our friend neil's war said
long ago prediction is very difficult
especially about the future
i'm not quite sure what else you would
predict but okay
that's the guy who came up with the
atomic model he's the reason we believe
that you have a an atom is actually a
bunch of protons neutrons in the middle
with some electrons whirling around the
outside it's a lie it's incorrect but
it's close enough for school work anyway
let's set the stage if we're going to
think about the next decade of software
we've got to talk about technologies we
know are already important and will
continue to be important like the cloud
the cloud has been progressing steadily
it's these days i think it's very hard
for you as a developer to not have some
thought about the cloud in any project
you're working on if you don't think
about it somebody's thinking about it
for you and so
how that affects our development we've
got to talk about moving forward because
it's continuing
same for the smartphone
the smartphone is the extension the
electronic extension humanity like you
got to think about it broadly enough
more or less it stopped changing
substantially when the iphone came out
in 2007.
you know before that phones were kind of
cool they had keyboards and
extra antennas and accessories and
things and after the iphone they're all
a slab of black glass you're holding one
right now
but what they did do was they penetrated
the whole of civilization pretty much
every adult human has some kind of
smartphone today and so we are all
cyborgs we don't generally think about
it that way because science fiction
tells us cyborgs have electronics like
in their head
but first you
and second slows down upgrades much
easier to upgrade it when it's on the
outside however the way you react when
you lose your phone like you lost your
head
so yeah it's a digital extension to
ourselves and again it affects
everything we do going forward if you're
communicating with the public you're
probably communicating with it through a
phone
most software these days has to have a
thought
to mobile in some ways and it's
significantly complicated everything we
do a lot of the struggles we look at
coming in these next few years are the
struggles we've had
which are how how do we deal with this
heterogeneous world of clients that
different kinds of phones and tablets
and pcs and so forth it's hard work
uh the side effect of both the cloud and
data and even the things that came
before it is the result of this huge
amount of data you can call it big data
if you want but that seems to be
underplaying the truth
we have
catastrophic amounts of information
emitting from our lives all the time and
a non-trivial number of companies that
profit from that information
mostly not us and typically you know i
say that to high school students all the
time if you don't pay for the product
you are the product
and that's part of our modern thinking
right and these are all the trend lines
there's nothing new here i'm describing
things you expect
more compute more devices more data
are you surprised no
so let's talk about things that are
going to change in the next 10 years the
real impact starting with moore's law
now moore's a nice man he's still alive
he's very elderly now
he's part of the company intel that made
the very first microprocessors in the
world
and that that was not the original
product of intel the original product of
intel was ram and he actually made this
observation talking about intel
manufacturing ram what he was really
saying was
for the same amount of money
roughly every two years we can double
the number of transistors on a given
piece of silicon
that's what he said
it got spun into being the law and all
these other things but it's not a law
right gravity is a law it doesn't matter
if you believe in it it's going to apply
to you
moore's law is actually the effort of a
tremendous number of people to advance
the manufacturing processes of silicon
and silicon chips
and it's running out we're getting
towards the end of it
starting in 1970 the original
microprocessor the 4004 up until very
recently
we have a very nice line going upward
the whole way now this is because we've
got a geometric progression really an
exponential projection on the left side
right if i take away that exponential
progression the graph isn't as pretty we
get the hockey stick
right because the number of transistors
is meaningless once you get into the
multiples of the current generation
now there's a better way to explain more
zlata to folks who aren't technological
i i show them one of these you ever seen
one of these
what is it warp drive from the suit from
the enterprise now that's this
this is a cray xmp supercomputer circuit
1985.
at the time the most powerful computer
in the world they only built a couple of
hundred of them they typically lived in
universities or in government labs they
ran about 16 million us dollars back in
1985 they were pushing the technology so
hard that in order to cool it they
literally had merged submerged all the
electronics in mineral oil and then had
a cooling system for the mineral oil the
reason the machine is curved is to keep
the wires as short as possible
the whole design was to optimize for
performance and it consumed about 200
kilowatts of power
so bring a couple of trucks worth of
generators if you want to run this thing
and it kicked out about 1.9 gigaflops of
processing power right so a billion two
billion floating point operations per
second
and at the time this is what we use to
model nuclear explosions and uh the
grand tour
satellite paths through the solar system
hard problems for civilization at the
time
fast forward 26 years 2011 the ipad 2
800 bucks
don't put in liquid that's bad
um
that's about a 25 watt hour battery on
it so it'll run for a day or two also
1.9 gigaflops
roughly the same performance as a cray
super computer just you play candy crush
on it
right or you keep children calm with it
here look at this stop yelling right
works remarkably well
that's moore's law in action that what
once was the most powerful computer on
the planet is now a device we give
children 26 years later and that's not
fast that's from 2011.
like today
as technological
fans the most advanced or high-powered
consumer electronics you could buy for
prospecting power would be a leading
edge video card if if you can find one
right but
an rtx 3090 which retails for about 1500
u.s or five thousand dollars on ebay
um we're running about ten thousand
cores this pushes out 36 teraflops
so eighteen thousand times faster than
that ipad
for about fifteen hundred dollars it
also consumes about 350 watts of power
so
put on a big fan
and that's still consumer electronics
right there is a if you talk about
top-of-the-line compute in the world
today you talk about the race that's
going on in super computers really
between china japan and the us
the current leading one is japan's
fugaku supercomputer with 7.3 million
cores
last test run that broke the record was
415.5
petaflops
or 12 000 times faster than the video
card
and 220 million times faster than the
ipad 2 and the cray xmp it also consumes
30 megawatts of electricity so bring
your own nuclear reactor
and costs about a billion bucks
what do you do with these things
they're super computers so there's a
certain
certain class of problem that actually
utilizes machines particularly well
analyzing the tracks of typhoons has
gotten very good in the recent years
it's these machines because they can
model the environment the atmospheric
behavior so well they're pretty good at
calculating strength and direction of
typhoons this is also the kinds of
machines that are used to build modern
aircraft airfoils so the 777x their
supercritical airfoil was modeled on a
supercomputer to figure out the optimal
airflow designs so there are certain
classes of problems that make sense for
these machines but they also give us a
high water mark
is are we going to have 400 petaflops of
processing power in the ipad 47
i don't know it's a good question right
we're going to keep shrinking down that
way but we do know that moore's law is
running out
right we've been following this graph
for quite some time
and in the end what was going on with
each with each iteration roughly in in
intel parlance they call it the
tick-tock cycle
is on the tick you would increase the
density
of the chip and on the top you would
improve the design of the chip to
optimize for the new density good one
and they're struggling to do that now
and the reason is
they're running out of atoms
so this is a
electron tunneling microscope image of
the ibm five nanometer process so each
one of the holes you're seeing there is
actually what would be a transistor
roughly five nanometers across now how
big is a nanometer it's a billionth of a
meter
which is too small for us to even think
about
the best way i know to describe a nano
anything there will be a nanometer or
nanosecond
is
to think in terms of seconds so if i ask
you to wait for a one million seconds
you can try this on your children it
won't work
i want you to wait for a million seconds
how long has you i'm gonna ask him to
wait for it's about 11 and a half days
so bring some water
if i ask you to wait for a billion
seconds
i'm asking you to wait for 32 years
so a nanometer is to a meter as a second
is to 32 years
right that's how big a billion is just
because we changed the letter it's three
orders of magnitude like it's a huge
problem and the issue here is that the
silicon atom itself
is a 111
picometers across or roughly 0.1
nanometers
so this is another tunneling microscopy
image of substrate
the yellow bumps are silicon
the blue holes are phosphorous
so in a in a five nanometer process
where you're down to about 45 atoms
across
and roughly every third atom will be
phosphorus for p-type silicon
you're talking about a dozen phosphorus
atoms
if anything goes wrong in here
there's any mistake in the array in any
way it doesn't work
so we're just getting so dense
that we don't have enough atoms and now
we get into quantum effects there's all
kinds of problems that happen once we
get down to this scale
now is it the end for us
well probably not
you know business is still business and
we have a lot of compute you may have
noticed that marketing has stopped
selling computers on the basis of the
number of transistors on the die
or the number of gigahertz because the
speed stopped going up one of the things
we found out when you get this small if
it gets too warm it really stops working
and so as we kept trying to press the
speed up those denser chips would fail
there are opportunities to move away
from silicon if you're into this space
and i am
you will see that intel and others are
working on things like gallium indium
arsenide which is a compound whose atom
atomic structure is quite a bit larger
than silicon but you need substantially
fewer of them to make a stable bit
so it is a possibility to continue for a
little while longer but there's another
side of moore's law that we don't think
about and it's the tendency for us to
not improve other things as long as
we're getting more compute every two
years
like if you know there's more compute
coming
you don't have a lot of obligation to
optimize you're gonna get performance
for free
it used to be because you knew the cpu
speed would go up but that hasn't been
true for 20 years now
and then it was as long as you could use
multiple cores you get speed for free
and we always get more cores for the
same amount of money
but we're already seeing the changeover
the big one is intel who has struggled
to ever really improve the chip design
essentially
with the x86 instruction set is making
the same check chip they started making
in 1984
and every time they tried to vary away
from that we get really angry about it
because it breaks compatibility and it
turns out compatibility is more
important to us than maximum performance
and so the architecture in an intel
chipset is very complex because it's
been built on layer after layer for the
better part of 50 years always with the
item maintaining compatibility
but there's another emergent very
successful chipset architecture the arm
architecture which intel was originally
involved in and they decided not to
bother with and sold off to texas
instruments and then it's changed a few
other hands and these days lives on a
bunch of different places but simpler
architectures which means fewer compute
cycles to the same workload
and now we have in the m1 chip
and now the m2 chip a processor so fast
and so efficient that it can emulate an
x86
faster than the x86 can
sucks to be you
we're going to see more of this as we
stop focusing on the rapid iteration of
moore's law and start focusing on how do
we actually use the compute we have in
more meaningful ways to increase density
to deal with new form factors
and for us as developers a lot of
hardware stuff we don't think about i
mean mostly.net developers in the room
hands please
oh yeah okay so i'm speaking to my
people
look the underlying processors
for net have changed every other year
since 2002.
new processes have been implemented and
removed so forth there used to be an
implementation for itanium.net
you didn't need to know
because your code compiles on demand on
the processors on that's just in time
compilation and now you're seeing
microsoft suddenly appearing with us to
be able to build
that on arm there's a reason for that
the code was on the shelf they'd done it
before
it doesn't take very long to implement
for more processors so
we're living at a time as developers
where in these modern languages
relatively speaking middlely.net is 20
years old
we are sufficiently abstracted from the
hardware then we don't have to worry
about that we're just going to be able
to expect to absorb the new hardware for
the things we're currently building
on the communication side because that's
our share limiting factor you may have
noticed a bit of advertising from your
local telcos talking about 5g everywhere
we pretty much have been
forced to have 5g phones no they don't
kill children or anything else
but they don't work particularly well
the simple rule in wireless
which is the the higher frequency you go
the more data you can cram in a given
cycle but the less distance you can and
things you can penetrate so low
frequency signal ranges like 900
megahertz come through buildings and
basements just fine high the all the
frequencies in 4g that were more in the
2 gigahertz range had more problem
penetrating buildings
5g to get the performance figures
they're advertising the ones you don't
get to experience
are 20 to 30 gigahertz frequencies and
they have tough time penetrating things
like
leaves
so if you have direct line of sight to a
5g tower and i mean literally nothing in
the way not even a cloud
you can get some stunningly good speeds
and in any other scenario you don't
and so you'll actually if you're in
again if you run the right software on
your phone and watch this you will watch
your phone routinely hop between your 4g
and 5g antennas as you turn around in a
circle
because your body will block 5g signals
just fine
now part of what the tel the reason they
pushed so hard on this is that certain
other entities were getting big on
putting satellite communications
infrastructure up starlink has done its
thing anybody got starlink down here
no a couple yeah i've got one up on the
co on my coast place which is you know
on the ocean kind of away from good
bandwidth
it works it's not better than gigabit
fiber but it's pretty good and it works
pretty much anywhere more or less
and but it's certainly not going to go
on a cell phone you know the dish is
still pizza sized and not particularly
portable and not particularly tolerant
to motion because it's using a
continuously steered
antenna inside that pizza box to track
the satellites as they whizz by
like you don't think a lot's going on
inside that that plate when you watch it
it just so it seems like it's sitting
there that's not true it's very very
busy thing and so in motion
substantially harder and clearly they've
had a role to play in ukraine
and there's been threats of other ones
being built but
once people start actually flying
hardware meaningful amounts i'll care
that and i but i did notice that since
the last time i was down here in 2019
when i flew
14 hours across the pacific ocean i had
free wi-fi the whole time
so i was text messaging about hi i'm in
the middle pacific because that's
hilarious to me
but uh you know you're not gonna watch
youtube videos doing that but it did
work
and yeah the current city of starlink is
is pretty impressive they're starting to
get up i get about 400 megabits down and
100 up at 20 nanoseconds which is like
decent cable modem speeds
and they say it'll continue it's i was
on the original beta
where it was off half the time as well
and much slower so it has steadily
improved and is much more reliable now
they're talking about putting the laser
layer in
i do own the domain name tech
billionaire or supervillain
i'm a little afraid to actually set up
the site but really all you want is a
questionnaire
right it's like
do you own an island
does your island have a volcano
do you have a
ship so large you have to point it with
park it with oil tankers
does it have a helicopter pad does it
have two helicopter pads
does it have a submarine does your
submarine have a submarine
do you fly lasers in space
who's the closest to being dr no
it's kind of a race it seems
but
what does this mean for the next 10
years
the concept is called ubiquitous
computing
moore's law means computers keep getting
smaller i if you've played with an esp32
it's a very mainstream chip i think you
can buy them on amazon now for five
bucks it'll run.net
size of your thumbnail
and if you're willing to go a little bit
bigger than that and it'll have wi-fi
and bluetooth on it as well
and then you combine it with ubiquitous
connectivity absolutely everywhere we
didn't have a choice right that we can
have as much computers we want in fact
we're going to be surrounded by compute
all of the time throw the cloud in there
where you literally have compute on
demands as long as you have a device
that can get out to that you can say hey
run this hard thing for me give me back
the results
so the idea that we have a single
personal computer and your cell phone is
your personal computer right i mean
what's more personal than a computer
that threatens to give you cancer
right it's in your pocket goodness knows
what it's doing to you
um
we are not going to focus on one
computer everything's going to have
computer around it all the time you'll
just be hopefully able to use it when
you need to which really brings us to
the real problem which is identity
what's going to happen in the next 10
years of identity
pain
that's all i got to say about that
and we'd be remiss not to talk about the
pandemic so what did the pandemic really
do
um besides keep us away from each other
for a couple of years so i mean who knew
a bunch of introverts would miss each
other this much
i am surprised but i missed you guys i
guarantee it uh our friend satya nadella
said that two years of cloud migration
happened in two months i do think when
we go back and write the history
somewhere in
april or may of 2020 was we got very
close to tipping over the internet like
the amount of additional stress that
happened on the backbones when everybody
moved home and software was trying to
figure out how to work remotely that
wasn't designed to work remotely
remember when the eu asked netflix to
turn off 4k mode
like that was the hint
hey we kind of need that bandwidth right
now
but we got through it obviously we got
another side not that big a deal for a
lot of us as developers you know we were
doing it beforehand
uh other than now we saw a whole lot of
people on
zoom and teams that weren't used to
being on zoom in teams and so although
remember that that actually went through
a wave too like for a while there the
emojis and the face changing stuff was
fun and after a while it's like none of
this is fun anymore and then you know
it's interesting to see the emergent
etiquette like it's very common now
everybody has their face on at the
beginning and then it's like okay well
this person's gonna talk and so we turn
all the faces off because it's like
you're paying attention by not paying
attention at least you're not showing
them you're not paying attention we'll
call that polite
um but we're also seeing not just as a
part as i would largely say still a
product of the pandemic they are the
economic impacts
so
the supply chain is severely disrupted
it still is severely disrupted the
ongoing lockdowns in china aren't
helping either it's going to take quite
a while to straighten all of that out
the inflation aspects and the great
resignation are all residuals of this as
well we've all had an interesting moment
in our in our way we're thinking about
things a lot of people have thought
about changing careers and the stress on
the infrastructure of society has been
substantial and some are taking
advantage of it some are not there's
lots of troubles here what does that
mean for us as software developers
because we're pretty resilient
right our need for software isn't going
away
in the problem is that you've had more
than 10 years and arguably 20 years if
you don't talk about the great recession
of 2008 2009 of continuous growth in
technology
where the job we were going we steadily
ran at a 20 unfilled job rate like we
had more demand for people than we could
train them if you wanted to get involved
in anything there were opportunities
non-stop and that largely still hasn't
really gone away in some ways it almost
accelerated briefly and it's like okay
well that's maybe a little too fast and
we're calming down a bit
but as someone who's written code in one
form or another for more than 40 years i
have been through a couple of real
recessions and i could always keep
writing code
because you focus on the return on
investment of that code
we forget
how effective our software is in making
businesses efficient
because we haven't had to think about it
for quite a while
but the reality is we amplify the
performance
of the whole company that one person can
do five times more work effectively
process invoices more effectively you
know complete data sets more effectively
and so if your projects are focused on
value for the company their demand is
only going to go up as markets get
tougher
if your product is not associated to how
the company makes money that's the one
that's probably going to get cut
right you are going to see folks needing
to economize the question i ask anyone
working in software is do you know how
your company makes money
because often it's not you
you build the tools that others in the
company make money with
and that's fine it's incredibly valuable
because often when you do a good job you
make those people dramatically more
efficient
just be aware how does this company make
money how does the project i'm working
on make a difference on that and you
only become more valuable but if you
don't know that association you're
vulnerable and you might get surprised
that's the the only thing that really
changes in these markets
okay
i've spent a good
20 minutes now setting the stage for
things let's talk about current
generation technology and how they're
evolving
the browsers aren't going away for the
most part they are the definitive smart
client technology for the average
company folks generally aren't
interested in anything else most of the
time it's been true for quite a while
they've matured nicely for the most part
you know the browsers all work and play
well with each other we have finally
really let ie go
although it's a lie
you know it's a lie right
the ie rendering engine is running on a
side inside of edge now if you need it
so if you're an i.t and you have an app
that was written for ie7
they exist and so you have the directive
that says run in ie7 mode edge now does
that for you
what they've really done is taken away
the icon
much angst about that
but you know that was part of the
problem with ie is that it kept every
previous rendering engine inside of it
that's why it got so huge it had all the
rendering engines in it and now it's in
edge because edge was just not big
enough
um the current the new generation ie6 is
safari
right because it's popular and not
compliant with standards that was the
problem with ie6 because it was the
default browser in xp and xp persisted
for so long and and ie6 shipped before
css1 was ratified so it was wrong
you ended up in that same problem as a
web developer where you had to build a
web page for all the browsers and a
separate one for ie6 or you wrote a lot
of if ie 6 code and today i talked to
developers saying exactly the same thing
i'm writing a lot of if safari code
apple's getting better but that's the
current stressor in that world the
progressive web app i i think we talk
about it routinely on the shows it's a
good technology i mean it's really about
making
browser apps more app-like
and if that makes you happy that's great
the question is are you happy
you know
folks some folks really like writing
javascript so and they're good at it or
they find the tool set that makes them
happy we talked about it on the show
it's like you're in the tribe of angular
there's a set of libraries that work
well with angular and you're happy there
and there's a certain class of products
you can build your company that are
valuable that they're going to be
content with or you're in the
or the react tribe or you're in the view
tribe or you're in that crazy vanilla js
tribe you're just gonna write all that
stuff yourself i put chris love on the
show every once a year or so just to
remind myself there's crazy ways to do
javascript too
and our friend steve sanderson who i'm
sad's not here but i've seen him a few
times
getting that implementation of.net
through web assembly
that eventually became blazer
any blazer fans
a few
i mean for the average corporate
developer who's been maintaining web
forms apps for years and years and years
this is a pretty interesting path
the biggest appeal for webassembly in
general is i need to build a web app but
i don't want to write in javascript and
so i can write in c sharp or i can write
in go
you know and there are other
implementations from there that's the
stick on web assembly although we have a
show coming up with sanderson
in the immediate future where we start
thinking about the idea that a web
assembly is actually a container
and you could choose where to run it we
already do it where we run it either in
the browser or run it on the server but
what if we could run it in intermediate
steps in between
a little brain twisting but i had a
great time carl's just like i don't know
what you people are talking about but
steve and i went off on a vendor on the
network is the computer and maybe web
assembly is the module of compute
i'd be remiss if i didn't mention web 3
because if you don't do a keynote with
at least one scam in it
you know you're not doing it right yeah
web 3 is being talked about a lot
there's a few elements of it that i find
are interesting and generalists are
three pieces decentralized web
blockchain crypto all right i'm not
talking but i don't really need to talk
about nfts too much
the one thing i think is super credible
in the space of web3 is the
decentralization of the web
so after the dot-com bust at the end of
2000 2001
where we were building a lot of our own
stuff and it was up to we had a lot of
servers on the internet that were
sitting under desks and a lot of them
that mysteriously went away
we recognized that running servers was
hard and so you could do it in the data
center with sufficient skill sets but
for most people it ended up being you
would buy a service right this
application service of one kind or
another cloud would eventually emerge
from this
but you think about the modern version
of geocities it became facebook
we started living in this walled garden
world because it was convenient but it
came at a price that price largely was a
complete aberration of privacy and
people exploiting your data for their
profit
you were the product
not the customer the customer was an
advertiser and so decentralized web as a
movement is saying hey
is there a way for us to resist the
walled garden
now we're not talking about putting
servers back under desks again we're
really talking about running it under
the cloud
and that still is a centralization of a
sort but it's a centralization where
you're paying for your service and so
you can have certain rights now this is
the battle that's going on from a
regulatory effort all over the western
world and further
to say what does decentralized look like
what are the responsibilities of the
cloud the cloud is headed towards this
idea of utility computing
and we've had we've created so
civilization has created utilities for
millennia our original utility was water
right when the neighborhood gets
together and digs a well utility water
and the romans build aqueducts utility
water right then we figured out hey if
you're going to bring water in you got
to take poop out so we built sewage same
thing another utility
we've experimented with others but
certain other ones have caught on
electricity seems popular
our jobs get really dull without it
and same for things like
uh internet connectivity and now cloud
compute by the minute where you really
only care about cost
and immediate availability
the upside to that is consistently
throughout civilization when something
becomes a utility becomes heavily
regulated because our expectation is it
just works and has no side effects
and so you can see in the next
few years bit by bit we will pit pretty
significant rules around cloud carriers
this is the same thing that happened in
telephony back in the day
when bank robbers started coordinating
their bank robberies on the telephone
the telephone company was not held
liable
for the crime they were the common
carrier
right
the cloud's going to be able to have
common carrier status you can build a
bad guy website on it but because they
hadn't they haven't controlled what you
put on there that's fine facebook can't
pull that off because facebook exploits
your data to sell stuff with it so
they're editorializing your data so they
don't qualify as a common carrier and
that's why they're in trouble with most
governments
another element of web3 that's relevant
is blockchain the only real problem with
blockchain is associated with crypto i
look at this the same as the association
between bittorrent and napster back in
the day there's nothing wrong with
bittorrent except it was contaminated
with stealing music
right
crypto is fundamentally a scam it was
born out of the frustrations of the
economic decline in 2008 and 2009 hey if
the bankers are going to
going to screw over the common man well
let's make our own currencies it's a
fine idea it's just that what you look
for in a currency is fungibility
reliability and stability
none of which exists inside of crypto so
it's only going to be on it's not been
having a good couple of weeks so it's
easy to feel like you're right doing
this talk when it was at 50 grand was a
little tougher
but right now at 22 it's like oh we're
okay but blockchain's got some good
ideas now distributed databases aren't
for everybody but the idea that you can
feed data in by consensus into a chain
of information where all parties
involved don't have to be on the same
page
completely like there's there's places
where that makes sense
not a lot of them but some so it's
clearly being overused and over
exploited right now but
it's one of those things like if this
interests you keep it in your pocket you
may run across a project at some point
where it'll be important and be able to
consume it because as certain
uh important projects emerge with it
you'll see it being used
uh ned's had a pretty good few years
i am still working on a book on the
history of dot net it may kill me
it's been a while but uh it's been a fun
ride gathering all the stories and
detail of the transformation that.net
went through
you know to start out as a product built
to sell copies of windows right it was a
tool to compete with java they didn't
want to say that back then but that was
the truth and it's the truth now
uh and to for enterprise developers to
build internal applications that was its
job
and then the operating system became
unimportant i mean we all need one we
don't care which one anymore and so the
idea that was bound any one operating
system is nuts microsoft has done a
phenomenal transformation of itself
after 30 years of being an operating
system company they are now a cloud
company and this is one of the products
that led the rest of the company into
you can transmute yourself
into a cross-platform open source
library and so effectively we had a
reboot of net it's just that we didn't
have to replace the tools
and depending on what libraries you
depended on many of your apps would just
simply move to the new library if they
depended on wcf you were sadder
right or web forms and you're much
sadder
i am very interested in continuing to do
shows uh around maui
and so maui is the fruition of them
trying to develop a new client strategy
and if you listen to dr rocks you've
noticed i've been talking about client
libraries non-stop the unos and the
avalons and all these other techs
the open silver which is a silverlight
implementation in open source that uses
webassembly like we're trying to find
ways to maintain old client technologies
in the modern world
and at the same time we're waiting for
this to come down the pipe i even did
shows on flutter i got phone calls for
doing shows about flutter
you know why are you talking about a
google technology on a dot-net show it
says cause it's awesome and maui is late
but uh
in the end
maui offers an is a consolidation of all
of the xaml experiments you know xaml
fragmented inside of microsoft with wpf
and silverlight and win phone and there
was a the the what became uwp which is
actually a different implementation than
what we were running over in dot net and
then you throw in xamarin forms on top
of all of that and they had to
rationalize it all
and it you know you'll notice miguel
isn't at the company anymore like the
rationalization was painful
but maui is bringing all those pieces
together to try and give us a coherent
client story
the question is why would you do this
versus sticking with web and it's and we
get we're going to talk about that
because it's very interesting that
there's so much interest on the client
on client technologies
containerization is going to continue to
evolve i sort of gave that away on the
on the web assembly part that that's an
interesting kind of container but in the
end we still have the same problem as
developers which is that
we need to run software in the context
of somebody else's machine where we
don't know what else is running and that
machine comes in lots of different form
factors so the better we describe the
requirements of our application both
what we need to operate on and what
we're going to consume and communicate
with represents a security perimeter and
a performance parameter
that's really what containers are about
right in traditional virtualization you
literally bundle the os in that seems
dumb so then we got to the docker phase
where it's like okay the os on the
outside just tell us which one you want
but if you look at it from a webassembly
perspective it's even smaller again
which like here's an op here's a sandbox
you can live in and run certain kinds of
code what do you want to do and if
that's sufficient for you it's a much
smaller container effectively but
containerization
the movement
continues because it addresses security
and distributed computing problems
you know okay this phone can't handle
this compute so let's go run it on an
edge device
and then just communicate down to the to
the phone like those are all become
possibilities that we don't have to code
if we have containerization correct
and if all this freaks you out
then you're not alone
look there's more than one way to have a
computing career
if you're working in a stack you really
like and you're good at
and you don't live for the next stack
you're happy where you are
you're not doomed
you're just going to have a different
kind of career you're going to be a
specialist
and that means you focus on
maintaining the feature set for your the
staff that you care about i talked to
folks who've been working in web forms
since 2002
and they have a you know it's like i'm
10 years away from retirement do i
really want to retool in maui like only
if you want to like it's a ride but
you've got a lot of things to learn if
you've been doing web forms like it's
2005.
but it's not like those web forms apps
are going to go away
you know what should you be working on
how do i make web forms work on a phone
it's possible i've done shows on it
right like you can continue to
specialize in a stack just recognize
there's going to be fewer opportunities
but those who need you really really
need you talk to a cobalt developer
today
because the mainframes just don't seem
to be turning off
and they're in their 60s they've been
paid more than ever before like i'd be
an idiot to retire right now because
there's nobody replacing them so if you
step off the new stack grind and onto a
stack you're going to care about you can
be that person just don't stop learning
you still need to learn you still need
to work in the development environment
your company is going to need and that
will evolve it's inevitable and you need
to be good at solving the problems
around your stack if you want to jump on
the new stack that's great i have
advertisers who want to talk to you
otherwise i have to get a real job so
listen to the shows those are the shows
we're making with the new stack but we
also made the shows about improving the
old stacks right i did a show on web
forms for phone development it's doable
it's just a question of where you're
going to stay in right there's not one
way to have a career there are lots of
choices and even though we are going
through one of the roughest patches for
software developers these next couple
years that we'll have had for literally
20 years before it's not that rough the
rest of the world's having a tougher
time you just got to figure it out
i would mention the power platform
briefly
this is i have seen this
this play before right history doesn't
repeat itself but it does rhyme
and in the in the middle 90s a set of
rad tools like visual basic and access
came along power builder and they
really appealed to the domain expert not
the programmer at the time the
programmer was a c plus plus developer
working in mfc or atl and they mocked
these tools mightily
because a domain
user somebody really knew a space could
sit down with these tools and get an 80
case done in a few days and ruin their
career it's like you used to be a
chemical engineer then you automated a
workflow now you're just a bad
programmer who knows something about
chemical engineering
right and the number of people in this
room that's like oh geez that's how i
got my career right like that happens
you had a domain expertise you got an
enamored of automation and you did it
this is a new generation of that this is
table stakes are cross-platform doesn't
matter which device you're using and
back ends on the cloud
now is there a role for like hey don't
mock it we've all been there and it's
not like any of us were getting to the
bottom of our to-do list
there's a whole lot of projects that can
be lifted up with tools like this to a
certain point
and the good news is for the most part
when they hit a wall
developers can step in and add the
additional capabilities right you can
build some apis that they're not easily
exposed or too complicated to use you
can build an additional ui compel
component that they can branch out to so
they can take the drudge app work off
you and you only work on the cool stuff
right now if you're more in the
management side these guys need guard
rails
they don't write a lot of tests they
don't know anything about source control
and uh and they don't know they're not
particularly concerned about security
sound familiar
right like young developers everywhere
and so we do need to help them do the
right thing with code our companies will
ultimately depend on
and if you want to try change up a
career completely a programmer working
in power platform you will blow some
minds like you can move fast because
you're not confused by a lot of stuff
the domain experts are
all right current stack stack stuff done
let's talk a little more futures let's
talk about artificial intelligence
now i pull up a picture of hal for a
reason the term artificial intelligence
is old it was coined in 1958 the
dartmouth university when they a group
of scientists were trying to extract
money from the u.s military to build
smart technology they succeeded to a
degree
but that term was invented then the
first time the public generally heard it
was in a movie from 1968
that kubrick wrote alongside arthur c
clarke the book actually comes out after
the movie they named it hal one letter
off of ibm they admit that was true and
of course our relationship with
artificial intelligence was cemented
when the first time most people ever
heard the term it was for a computer
that tried to kill everybody
so we set ourselves on the path right
and then par part of the problem we have
with ai is that it's a blanket term
largely for stuff that doesn't work
particularly well yet because once it
does start to work we give it a name
right we break it out so the umbrella
term is ai but and this i love this
diagram just because it starts things
out so well the shortest lines here like
that planning scheduling and
optimization part that was what um
minsky and their guys were working with
in the 1950s that the us military got so
much value from then in the 1970s it's
expert systems and robotics and the
lines just keep getting louder as we get
better and better technology
the current revolution that we're
enjoying in ai comes from
about 2011 with the imagenet competition
and the adversarial network or the smart
neural network that allows for image
identification
it doesn't always go particularly well
but this is technology that can be
incorporated into software today it's
quite reasonable to do that that you can
add if your image recognition is
valuable to you you know you think
through a workflow with a tablet i talk
to bankers now that are taking the
tablets to the customer the customer
thinks it's a service but in reality
what they're doing is really assessing
whether you can pay
and how your home looks and your at and
the things you own look tells a lot
about your ability to pay far more than
any form you would ever fill in and so
using the software in the tablet to take
pictures of things and have them
automatically recognized and categorized
makes them better bankers in the end
they have fewer defaults on loans
because they select folks more
effectively by their ability to pay
and that brings us to the biggest part
of the modern machine learning movement
is in data analytics so
the
we started out with good old-fashioned
reports you still build a bunch of them
although i'm sure they're not as popular
as they used to be and then predictive
analytics is sort of the mainstream
approach today where we're starting to
say okay if last month sold this much
what does next month look like what does
next year look like those kinds of
things and we have these were originally
all data mining functions we'd run an
olap services back in the 90s and 2000s
if you had several million dollars to
spend on gear
today
this is a cloud service you can run for
an hour against a data set cost you less
than 100 bucks so you can experiment
with data analytics in a way you've
never been able to before and if your
company is not taking advantage of this
you're looking for a new opportunity
this is a huge space
but we can go further as we start adding
machine learning models in now we're
doing things like we're simply trying
every model and then comparing them
automatically so instead of having to do
a lot of planning it's just brute force
because we have so much compute
available to us the machine learning
models are getting better the hip term
today is now what we call prescriptive
analytics and in prescriptive analytics
you're actually pred you're now picking
proposing an action against an entity
and then assessing with predictive
analytics what it would do so i mean one
hand is the sales process how often do
you send someone an email about you i'm
sure you're getting these right now an
abandoned
cart in an e-commerce site hey we
noticed you put these strings things in
your cart you know if you order you pick
that up maybe you just forgot about it
just want to let you know about it then
the next email is i'll give you 10 off
one of them
or how about free shipping right i mean
and that's all automated there's no
person sending you those emails right
that's this prescriptive analytics play
and if you want to get away from the
e-commerce marketing side of this you
get more into things like
does it make more sense to evacuate a
neighborhood for a forest fire knowing
that will kill a certain number of
people the stress of evacuating or wait
right we're getting better with software
to know the right you may
if we evacuate them earlier even though
it'll cost a bunch of money it's fewer
risk of the risk of life right the
models are getting really good at
figuring that stuff out same for
flooding or when do we start hitting
setting up cooling centers for heat
waves you notice i'm doing a lot of
climate change stuff i've been watching
your news you guys had a tough couple of
years
in british columbia we went back to back
with heat dome where we had one city
that had the one town that had the
highest temperature in canada three days
in a row and the third day it burnt to
the ground
followed by
completely buried in forest fire smoke
for a month then it rained so hard it
wasted out washed out all of the
highways and put a big chunk of farmland
underwater and at that point we said
like what's next the plague of
but yeah we've all been having
challenges with that i actually looked
at a
prescriptive analytics service uh that
was being used for
when to replace a power generation
turbine
so based on and it's all those different
factors simultaneously so what is the
current power demand can we afford to
have that turbine down what's the
likelihood of it failing inside of that
window what's the availability of the
components to do the upgrade on it you
know picking the right moment to order
the parts get everything organized and
actually take it down and do the work on
it
modern data analytics does a way better
job of this and so it's a growth area
it's a tremendous amount of work to be
done there
uh ai and programming well you can make
a video game by describing it in texts
right this is the open ai codex project
so using gpt3 or if you've gotten into
github copilot
it's kind of looking like stack overflow
on steroids basically now i'm writing
out phrases that just search for code
for me written by other people um
there's been some great demos with this
where a guy said i don't know rust but i
want to make a hello world
website with rust and literally describe
that need to co-pilot it gave him all
the code to compile and run on rust and
boom he had a hello world
they're all experiments
but it also speaks to a trend for us
over the next few years you know i ask
guys like mads torgenson you know the
the guy who's leading the she sharp
project right now it's like you never
make backward compatibility you've left
all these features in c sharp going back
to the original you're up to 11 now
you've got all better ways to do things
like how are you going to convince us to
do it the new way it's like it's about
the tooling
so can we get to a point where there's
machine learning models smart enough to
look at your code and saying hey you're
kind of programming this in a c-sharp
six style let me show your refactoring
in c sharp 11.
yeah okay apply that
and so help you learn the new versions
right ai is not going to replace us as
programmers it has no autonomy yeah i
know google had their we have a sentient
computer thing pretty sure that's not
true
uh but you know we're we are
finding we are good at building tools
that's what humans do the straight path
between the stick for pulling ants out
of the ground
and co-pilot right these are tools that
allow us to extend our own creativity
efforts and needs
into our current workspace
they're just continuing
one last thing before we were out of
time here and that is what replaces the
smartphone
smartphone is pretty much mature right
it gets bigger it gets smaller it has
one camera has two cameras has three
cameras it has an ir catalog whatever
they're all more or less the same
we kind of hit the wall on it what's the
logical next step and most likely it is
the visor of some kind this is a mock of
supposedly what apple's going to present
us with in the next year or two
uh it'll be tethered to the phone so the
phone will still be the compute device
the
watch may or may not exist this is a
mock-up it's not real but the bottom
line is
having information directed directly
into your eyes and having a camera on
your head
seems to be the logical path
yeah nobody wants to be a glass
okay
i have a google glass i have worn the
google glass i mean not recently but
when i first started wearing the google
glass out i had exactly the same
experience i had when i first had a
smartphone which the people see it go
can i try it
then when they try it and it's not good
then they make fun of it
right but remember what happened when
you got a smartphone nobody else had a
smartphone and somebody said can i try
it and then you couldn't get it back
from them
and that's what's going to happen with
augmented reality devices once they get
to that point they'll be good enough and
you won't don't give it to anybody
because they're going to take it
right they will be profound now again
his you know
the future is not evenly distributed we
do have google glass that's a real uh
product you can buy today from qualcomm
it's called the xr1 again with the
android device on the outside
um this is more toshiba's version of
this more industrial
so the camera and so forth just over one
particular eye and of course we've got
hololens this is the trimble xr10 which
is actually integrated with your hard
hat because it's designed for
construction or working in industrial
plants and this is a field unit they're
about five thousand dollars a shot
i look at
augmented reality at this moment
where we're seeing workers use them to
do complex tasks
so they have to do a maintenance on a
jet turbine or on a machine and instead
of looking through the book or you know
looking to a tablet they literally have
their checklist in front of their eyes
in fact the best ones won't show them
the next item until it's analyzed that
you finish the previous item remove this
screw and then it's watching you remove
the screw in fact the video record of
all of the work is an important part of
the equation and when you hit a point
where you need an assessment by an
expert you then request that expert
who's somewhere else in the facility
they put their glasses on now looking
through your camera at the same thing
you're looking at and give you that
information and it's also recorded as
part of the path
so pratt and whitney's
c-class tear down of jet turbines that's
a 50 million dollar jet turbine doing a
5 million service it takes about a month
to do all the work on that turbine
before it goes back on an airplane now
on on and every part has to be
authenticated that it's a the real part
and all the steps were followed
correctly and so the fact that they
bought a bunch of 5 000 headsets and run
about a thous about a thousand dollars a
month per headset in back-end services
makes total sense for them
it's a multi-million dollar product it's
not for everyone
this reminds me
of the blackberry
in 1998
right back in the west wing era when
they called it a crackberry because back
then they were about a thousand bucks
and they were the only phone that had
email on them and you had to run a
customized version of exchange on the
back end with the blackberry exchange
management system and it cost a lot of
money to take a lot of people to run but
if you needed certain people to have
email on their phone at all time it was
a breakthrough
and then it got commercial it got turned
into consumer product with the iphone
the iphone took a few years to get it
right
the hardware problem is substantial
hololens has stuck to their guns on
putting everything on the visor where
most production units you're looking at
right now are tethered they have a they
have a glasses on with a cable running
to a pouch on your back with a phone
with an extra battery on it because this
thing mows through battery power
but
we didn't see the hololens 3 this is the
hololens 2 which is circa 2017. the 3
was originally developed for the us
military and then they changed a bunch
of the rules so they scrapped it at the
prototype stage so we are
two
tick-tock intel cycles behind on
augmented reality headsets
we had can and that means one of two
things we're either cutting the price in
a quarter for the same hardware or
adding a bunch of additional
advancements and keeping it relatively
expensive so or some balance in between
we're very close
and this is where we get into that whole
conversation about client stacks
because web ain't going to cut it in
this thing now this is normal when we
have a major change in form factor or
devices
that we have to go fairly native the
main way that folks are programming a
hall lens right now is unity
so keep your c sharp skills sharp if you
want to play in this field but also a
lot of 3d learning a lot of ways of
thinking about it i've seen some
demonstrations of the hololens of coding
in the hololens where the guy's typing
on a keyboard blind because he's looking
through the visor at the space that he's
working anybody's creating objects and
looking at the code through the visor
which is cool it's very matrixy
but you know we don't know what that'll
look like yet that's a that's a
progression that's ongoing and i'd be
remiss if i didn't mention meta
apparently zuckerberg is capable of
burning through 10 billion dollars in
less than two years because they're now
having cutbacks and laying people off
they were paying basically top dollar
for anybody who wanted to work on it i
know some really great people who went
over to facebook to work on it's
actually called horizon world
the reality of course is that facebook
has such a reputation that most other
companies that want to do something in
this metaverse space are staying very
hush-hush including microsoft because
they don't want to be contaminated with
the fallout of what facebook's doing
i mean if you think about what
facebook's trying to do in virtual
reality they're trying to recreate
second life
as a
uh a product for advertisers because
that's all what they know how to do they
know how to build a social media site
you're trying to build something out of
nothing effectively it's not a
particularly good strategy
all right last couple of minutes let's
talk a little quantum computing because
it's been getting hot around there
first off you hear all the news about
quantum computing will destroy
encryption don't worry about that
there's two reasons one is the
encryption problem is extremely hard for
quantum computers to solve they will
solve it eventually but many more things
will happen before that happens and
second is we are perfectly capable of
building encryptions not dependent on
prime numbers which is why quantum
computers can break it we just haven't
needed to change it the moment we decide
we do need to change it we will it'll be
tls 2 3.5
and it'll use ladder-based encryption
which is not as compute computationally
efficient as rsa encryption but does not
susceptible what quantum computers do
quantum computers are a very difficult
problem in order to have functional
qubits
in the current state of technology you
have to cool semiconductors down with
liquid helium which means running
somewhere around one to two degrees
kelvin
colder than space
and then you also have to get
information from it which means putting
energy into it which usually screws that
up
so you've got this duality problem where
you need it very cold and stable but
you're still trying to read information
from it typically through magnetic
fields there's been a bunch of progress
on that area so the sycamore which is
google's current one in 2019 had 54
qubits although test was only 53 cubits
because one of the qubits was broken but
they did a test using a random number
problem that's specific to quantum
and the run was about 200 seconds and
proved that it was a quantum problem and
they initially said this will take 10
000 years of conventional computer ibm
their rival then did the problem in a
day and a half with a conventional
computer but not 200 seconds
so i think we'll leave the quantum
supremacy like they finally done
something that fast with quantum good
enough the chinese with the xiang
photonic quantum computer completely
different design not even remotely
similar to the fermion design that quan
that that google used uh in 2020 they
got up to 113 entangled qubits they did
a boson sampling quantum problem again
about a 200 second run current estimate
to do that with classical computers
would be about two and a half billion
years
i'm sure abby i'm going to improve on
that by down to i know 100 million years
but we would take a while to find that
out
ibm's latest this is the eagle 127
tangled qubits
using the transmon architecture totally
different approach again
and they
they have are currently doing testing on
it we haven't gotten good results yet
they swear by the end of this year
they'll have a 433 cubic computer when
is this going to do anything useful
because right now you're doing
random number problems in bose and
assembly probably whatever so let me
talk about a useful problem we have
today that we feel could only be cracked
with quantum computers and it's in
agriculture
now today in modern agriculture
we know that if you plant wheat in the
ground and you harvest it the next year
if you plant wheat again the wheat is
smaller
because you've taken a bunch of
nutrients out of the soil we fixed that
by adding fertilizers to the soil and we
use a thing called the haber bosch
process it was developed in world war
one it happens to also make explosives
because that's life for you could be
explosives could be fertilizer to save
the world
uh it now consumes about one percent of
all the energy that humans produce
to make fertilizer for food
to put those nutrients back in the soil
and yet we knew before we knew how to
make fertilizer that you could rotate
crops that if you plant wheat one year
and then next year you plant beans the
beans the roots on the beans actually
when you plow them under let them sit
for a year to rot put re-fertilize the
soil crop rotation
and we've studied the bean plant to say
how does the bean plant do this little
trick and it has a rhizome that grows on
the roots and little cysts and inside of
is an enzyme called nitrogenase and
nitrogenase
makes fertilizer
it takes water out of the air and
nitrogen out of the air combines it into
ammonia
at plant energy levels we have these
huge factories for making fertilizer and
plants have been doing it for
millions of years
now we have studied this for a hundred
years and know that it is a catalytic
reaction between iron and molybdenum
that somehow combines the nitrogen and
and hydrogen together
we just don't know how it works
there's about 170 electrons involved in
the catalytic reaction
and to compute all the variations of how
those electrons would interact is more
compute power than we have on the planet
but a 250 cubic computer should knock it
out in about five minutes
now what would that mean for society if
we were actually able to do that well it
would mean a we would stop making
fertilizer at such huge scale this is a
low energy way to make it now just
because we know what the catalytic
reaction is doesn't mean we necessarily
know how to recreate it so there's
plenty of engineering work to be done
but you can imagine
being able to make fertilizer in situ
like a little
steak with a watch battery on it you
stick in the ground beside your plant
and it monitors how much fertilizer is
available to plant or how much nitrogen
phosphorus potassium is available to
your plant and then pulls it out of the
atmosphere and puts it in the soil on
demand
so less problems with fertilizer runoff
far less energy consumption like it's a
green revolution if we knock it out
that's one quantum chemistry problem
there's about 300 known ones that are
all sitting waiting for a quantum
computer somewhere between two and 500
cubits to make it work
batteries are essentially alchemy we
just try different combinations to see
if we get a good one we do not
understand the interaction of how
batteries actually work it's too complex
quantum computing can help us in this
space it would mean a substantial jump
in the possibility of power storage
superconductors we kind of understand
what's going on in super conductors now
we start to call it a phase of matter
we've had an accidental improvement in
rebco uh superconductors back in the 80s
we still don't really understand how it
works quantum computers can solve that
one here's the problem with all these
very cool problems once you crack them
you've cracked them
they're deterministic problems
so how many quantum computers do you
need
if this is the class of problem you have
and that reminds me of thomas watson and
ibm back in the day who said yeah we
think there's a market for like five
computers well a it's a totally a
profitable statement he didn't actually
say that and b he was clearly wrong but
why did he say it well at the time this
is what computers look like right they
were bespoke machines you built them
specific into a building came with a
bunch of guys in lab coats they had
names
right they were not like computers you
think of today they also hadn't figured
out the bit yet they were doing bits
with vacuum tubes and relays they were
they took a while before they finally
got to
the silicon bit
right that ultimately was manifest with
intel
and the the person that that um moore
and
all those guys that became intel they
originally worked for company called
fairchild semiconductor and the the
fellow there was a guy named shockley
apparently an unpleasant person but also
one of the guys who helped invent the
transistor at bell labs and he was the
one who came up with the original
concept of the integrated circuit of
using layers of silicon
with doped with different substrates
with boron and phosphorus stacked
together to make these tiny transistors
that's responsible for all of our jobs
in shockley's own notes as he was
learning he was exploring the idea of
making the semiconductor this way
he used a mechanical computer of the day
to compute the model
to be able to
actually understand how he would that
phosphorus was the correct element to
use for doping for p-type silicon
substrates
i think that's where we are with quantum
computer it rhymes for me in history
that this current bespoke unstable
expensive unique individually named
quantum computers are going to be
sufficiently powerful for us to actually
figure out what the correct qubit should
be
what the modern quantum transistor will
ultimately look like and then they
transform you can't look at this
and think of this
right there's no path from this kind of
mainframe to playing candy crush so
i don't know
what's going what quantum computers will
ultimately mean for us but i do know in
the next 10 years
quantum computing will start having an
impact on civilization
they'll start solving certain classes of
problems and one of them will be
building better computers with it in
general
and so if we think beyond that time
space what's next
here's the best part of our job
we get to choose
this is our industry we help make all
these things come true you want to know
what's going to happen next in the
future make it it's up to us
thanks for your time and have a great
show
[Applause]
you